[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
it's hump day
i don't know how happy it is
i want to wish you a happy hump day
but we have republican kid diddlers
[Music]
running around the country
sexualizing your kids gender
and wanting to marry them at any age
at any age these republican kid diddlers
want to marry your kids
you know i i've been i've been yelling
and screaming into this microphone for
months and months and months saying hey
hey they're going to come after you
they're going to come after your kids
it's not it's not just transgender kids
it's not just women's wombs anymore it's
not gay children anymore
they're coming after all children they
want to marry them
they want to marry him
i don't believe me don't believe me just
look to tennessee
just look to tennessee
what they're doing in tennessee is
making it to where right now currently
the the age of consent for marrying is
17 in tennessee
and they don't want to change the
consent age to 18 or 16 or 15 which is
gross
want to do away with it all together
they want to marry your babies
disgusting vile [ __ ]
these republican kid diddlers this is
what these fascists do this is what they
do this is their mo this is how it works
they continue to paint all democrats is
the blood sucking cabal a band of
pedophiles
it's all projection
doubt me doubt me about the projection
it's time it's time to use messaging
to win the 2022 midterms folks it's time
it's time
the time is now
not not next month not the month after
not the month before the midterm now is
the time
to fight the fight that these fascists
want to fight
they're gonna win on policy folks for
the time being don't let you don't get
discouraged
that's what they want you to do
is to get discouraged about the policy
losses
like in florida the don't say gay bill
they won that policy
they won the policy fight they passed
that disgusting bio [ __ ] bill
and ron desantis that nazi bigot in
florida
signed the don't say gay bill
and now now is picking a fight with
disney because disney knows it's wrong
not because disney is some kind of woke
company
other than its employees said hey
[ __ ] you either support this or
we won't work here [ __ ] you
and disney's disney ceo said you're
right i should stand with equality and
equity for all
and that's what they're doing
and that's the fight that ron desantis
is fighting against is equality and
equity
and meanwhile in tennessee
we have
a bill where a rapist family can sue a
woman for being raped
i'm not [ __ ] you
not only that they want to make sure
they want to make sure that that rapist
can marry that child
doubt me doubt me
you don't think their next step is to
dictate who can marry who you don't
think that powerful white wrinkly old
ball sack men aren't going to tell you
that they can marry your child and
there's nothing you can do about it not
a goddamn thing you think that's you
think that's not their next step you
think this is rock bottom with these
fascists with these with these let's go
brandon nazis these
republican kid diddlers do you think
that's the end
do you think this is rock bottom with
these gop pedophiles
hell to the no
we must protect our democracy we must
protect our country and we must protect
our children from these republican
kidnaddlers
it is dire circumstance the time is now
it is now
and it is not it is not oh well there's
those republicans in these republicans
[ __ ] no
we have to stop with that [ __ ] both
sides both parties are different there's
different republicans than this or that
nope they're all
republican kid diddlers from here on out
if you're republican and you claim and
you identify as a republican you're with
them
you're with them
the ones who want putin to commit war
crimes
the ones who don't want you to be able
to say the word gay
who want trans children and gay children
and trans parents and gay parents to be
ostracized from society
you're with them
you're a bigot
you're not for equality you're not for
equity you're not for democracy
you're a fascist you're a let's go
brandon nazi
a republican kid diddler
take it to the bank
we have to win this war on messaging
folks
and they're giving us everything we need
everything we need
to finally bury trumpism in this midterm
you don't think this is trump
republicans
you don't think that these people in
tennessee who are trying to make sure
they can marry babies
are [ __ ] believe the crt voodoo the q
and on [ __ ]
you don't think you don't think they
believe that the election was stolen and
joe biden isn't the president somehow
barack obama is the shadow president you
[ __ ] don't think that get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] full stop 100
percent their trump republicans the
republicans who are kid diddlers who are
gop pedophiles are trump republicans
it's time
it's time we fight
it's time we win this election
now right now not tomorrow not the next
day not next week not next month not
during the summer right now
we can win the messaging the perfect
example is florida in the don't say gay
bill
republicans down there are completely
pissed completely pissed
that democrats won the messaging of
don't say gay it doesn't say don't say
gay go read the bill
go read the line items in the bill how
it discriminates against gay people it
doesn't say don't say gay it just
discriminates
as long as it doesn't say don't say gay
but democrats won the messaging yes yes
we are going to lose on policy we lost
supreme court seats we are going to lose
on policy in tennessee and in missouri
and in texas and in louisiana and in
florida we're going to continue to lose
on policy but if you think that's the
end if you think that's what that's just
the way it is let the nazis have it then
we're [ __ ] anyways
but there's still fight left in us
81 million people didn't vote for joe
biden
81 million people voted against trumpism
and they're our coalition
they're here
they're here all around the country we
see in school board elections
in school board elections these crt
voodoo [ __ ] are losing
this trumpism is losing everywhere
in local elections because people know
it's all [ __ ] garbage
this facade this fraud
that trump has big support
it's time
it's time we take back our democracy
it's time we take back our country
it's time we stop these republican kid
diddlers from passing pedophile bills
i'm telling you they're going to try to
out tennessee tennessee florida's next
then texas then missouri
then louisiana oklahoma decided that
women have no liberty whatsoever
at all
you don't think oklahoma's gonna pass a
pedophile bill
hide
and watch
or
get your ass out there and participate
in this democracy
and i'm not just talking about voting
you have to vote in every election right
from now until the end of time
every every election is the most
important election every [ __ ] one of
them
because they're not gonna quit
they're not going to if you haven't
noticed
the time is now to participate to
participate in our democracy
when you're at your church when you're
at your school when you're at the
grocery store when you're with your
[ __ ] family
your friends you tell them
that the republican kid diddlers want to
marry your babies
they want to marry your babies don't
believe me
you don't have to believe
me you do not have to believe me
why are why
why other than the republicans want to
dittle kids in tennessee would they pass
a bill
that removes the age their age to be
married why
what would be the purpose
what is the purpose of removing the age
of being married in tennessee if they
don't want to diddle kids
what could possibly be
what could possibly be the explanation
i'm waiting
i'm waiting and i know there's gonna be
video
video of these vile republican kid
diddlers who are going to try to defend
this stuff
these gop pedophile bills
and again it's not just going to be in
tennessee folks
it's not just in tennessee
they want to sexualize your kid's gender
sexualized gender kids children gender
and they want to marry them
you don't think they're gonna you think
they're just gonna stop there
men empower white men in power
white men in power are going to tell you
what they're going to do with your
children
and you think they're just going to stop
it at
oh well the the parents will give
consent you don't think they're the
powerful will take consent away from you
they're taking consent away from
complete consent away from women in
oklahoma over their over their uterus
100 percent full stop taking away
consent in their liberty of their bodies
their autonomy
you think they're going to stop at women
and children
white dads white suburban dads out there
that are listening you think they're
gonna stop at your wife and your
children
you think the powerful
apparatus of the fascist are gonna stop
there
look at history
and know
that it's time to stand
it's time now is the time today
to stand against these republican kid
diddlers
and your proof is in the pudding they're
passing gop pedophile bills as we speak
and boy they can't wait for these bills
to become law
they can't wait
i'm fired up this morning and i'm going
to stay fired up and so should you
everyone's here this morning i want to
say hello to everyone uh debbie lisa
christina kaylin's here jeannette is
here kathy is here mj good morning brent
is here
jamie from facebook is here jay is here
andrea's here
anita is here
jamie from facebook um
there's so many lacy from facebook
forest from facebook is here you guys
know that we broadcast every single
weekday every one of them monday through
friday and we are gonna burn down this
republican kid diddler house
here on the tony michaels podcast we're
not [ __ ] around
hol no holds bar we're not gonna hold
back no [ __ ] to give we're gonna burn
it down and it's time the time is now
we're going to get the messaging right
we're going to get the messaging out
there so spread this around
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central for two
hours
on youtube twitter twitch and now on
midas touch facebook page
go to thetonymichaels.com follow us
everywhere
not just not just me
at tony michael's pod but the tony
michaels follow my co-host at gabe's at
i am gabe sanchez we
we are prepared
here at our show
to make sure
that these republican kid diddlers know
we are not messing we are not messing
around when it comes to them passing gop
pedophile bills in red states that they
want to sexualize our kids genders
and they want
to marry them
they want to marry your babies
put that in a box figure out figure out
how that's electable in this country
it's time it's time time is now to fight
the messaging
and we have we have the messaging on our
side
we're going to get an update here very
very soon right after the break aaron
parnez is going to join us for an update
of the war crimes that putin is
committing in ukraine
it's very important not to look away at
these issues
we cannot let these people distract us
we have to keep our eye on the ball the
messaging has to be real and it has to
be in your face
the midterms is important if we don't
want putin-style politics
here in our country stick around we will
be right back with aaron parnez in an
update
in ukraine right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out of the natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thank you for staying through the break
we have a special guest
aaron carnes he's gonna give us updates
on ukraine and the war crimes that
putin's committing there there's been a
lot of news in the last week
i want to get his take on things and
make sure you're in the comments if
you've got a question for aaron um we
will try to bring your question into the
show i want to welcome aaron barnes back
to the show aaron how are you i'm doing
well how are you it's good to be back i
i am i am doing great i'm a little fired
up this morning because of some of the
bills that these republicans are really
trying to
push in this country through the
legislator um
in tennessee the the the recent gop
pedophile bill is is uh just one of the
bills that the tennessee legislator one
of the disgusting the disgusting bills
that the republicans in tennessee are
pushing through um you know all around
the country they're really trying to
push these bills through and a lot of
people don't really recognize
that a lot of this stuff is putin-style
politics
and that's why i wanted to have you on i
wanted you really to give us an update
of ukraine um i know you have family
there so you have some special insight
into that but i know you've been
following the story very very closely
yesterday we seen president zelinski
actually addressed the u.n security
council he was very upset that they're
allowing russia to still veto things um
can you tell us a little bit about that
and why you think that's important and
then we'll get to um the
unfortunate and vile massacre the war
crimes that uh putin has committed in
bucha but tell us yesterday about what
president zielinski said and and give us
insight into that yeah so essentially
president zielinski kind of gave the
united nations an ultimatum either
reform and kick russia out of the
security council and actually hold
russia accountable
or just dissolve yourself as a body
because if you're not holding russia
accountable what's the point of you
doing any work and what's the point of
us funding you right so the united
nations security council is a group of
15 countries five permanent states and
10 non-permanent states that rotate um
every once in a while and the five
permanent states are russia the united
states china france and the united
kingdom and all the five permanent
states have veto power over resolutions
and over actions taken by the united
nations security council
so we need to kick russia out of that
security council because thus far russia
has vetoed any resolution concerning
condemnation uh of russia's actions in
ukraine um russia can veto any
resolution calling for the
united nations peacekeepers to enter
ukraine for example any any action taken
by the united nations russia has the
power to veto right now and president
zielinski is literally saying hey what's
the point
of the united nations existing and
what's the point of you guys issuing all
these strong words if you're not going
to stand by um
your words by actually taking strong
actions like kicking russia out of the
security council like providing more
weaponry to ukraine like potentially
even enforcing a no-fly zone which is
what he's been asking for for a long
time so yes he really gave them this
ultimatum
so what do you do do you think that
ultimately the u.n security council will
heed his words do you think um that is
possible or do you think they're still
playing footsie because vladimir putin i
mean you know the word is is the the
reason why the u.s hasn't committed um
more troops
and
because we've
we've
really committed weapons and money um
through nato
but it doesn't seem like the commitment
is there um to ultimately crush putin i
think that's his beef here but do you
think it's still the nuclear weapon
threat that vladimir putin poses do you
think that's some of it and you do you
really think uh the second question is
do you think that the u.n will heed his
advice well first off i think that the
nuclear weapon threat is was always
there is always going to be there i
don't think that it's anything different
today than it was
14 years ago when it when russia first
invaded georgia or eight years ago when
russia invaded crimea i think in
international law we have the concept of
mutually assured destruction and putin
knows as well he's not going to launch
nuclear weapons because he knows that's
a suicide mission and at the end of the
day um putin's ultimate goal here is to
ensure a strong quote mother russia
and mother russia won't exist if putin
launches nuclear weapons because the
united states china and others global
superpowers will also launch nuclear
weapons and you will have mutually
assured destruction so i don't think
it's necessarily about nuclear weapons i
think it's more to the fact that the
united states doesn't want to get
involved in an actual conflict with
russia i don't think the united states
wants um us troops dying in a potential
conflict with russia i think that's
where this is really coming from from
and i think that right now vladimir
putin is not really acting rationally
he's not the rational actor many thought
him to be
so if the united states states take
certain actions like removing russia
from the security council or um
providing more high-tech weapons to
ukraine putin may take that as a sign of
aggression and launch a cyber attack
against the united states might launch
an act of war against the united states
somewhere in europe something like that
so that's why i don't think we've seen
enough action from the united states and
elsewhere yet and regarding your second
point
it's difficult to say i think the united
nations is going to take kind of like
this piecemeal approach and first
they'll look to ban russia from the
united nations human rights council
which i'm shocked that their salon but
then again the human rights council
had previously had member states like
north korea cuba and venezuela on as
well so
it doesn't really mean much um but i
think they'll take a piecemeal approach
and start there and then maybe get to
the security council eventually but i
don't i don't i don't see it happening
immediately even though it should
well
and and i i agree with you i i don't
think the u.n is going to just um
just absolutely ban uh russia i i think
the the point is of the united nations
is to you know keep your allies close
but your enemies closer kind of thing
sometimes um that's their approach to
things now rather that's right wrong or
indifferent or if it will drag us into a
world war you know that that that is to
be told
um speaking of war and war crimes uh
we've seen this week that vladimir putin
and the russian army committed absolute
war crimes and atrocities and um am i
saying you're right bucha is that yeah
um
the president zilinski went to bucha
there's been a lot of video a lot of
footage
from bucha which is
a vile horrible genocide of innocent
women and children and men in that town
it seems as if from from the evidence
that
they were just uh executed um
in just horrible ways and then
almost immediately russia turns it
around and says it's all staged and it's
fake and um even even more vile
propaganda coming out of russia
can you tell us a little bit about your
feelings of bucheck because i know the
president united states joe biden has
said that hey we need to make sure
that these war crimes are paid for um so
so tell me tell me about that event
and the things that you've seen
and then what your feeling is on if
putin will pay for these war crimes yeah
i mean personally it's terrible it's
awful to witness and i think it's not
just in buchets it's throughout ukraine
as ukrainian soldiers are taking back
territory and taking back cities we see
more and more evidence of war crimes i
mean we now have reports this morning
from mariupol where russian crematoriums
are being brought in to
burn essentially dead bodies to hide
evidence of war crimes and tens of
thousands of people have died in that
port town way more than
were killed in bucha but still um it's
it's these atrocities are have been
committed all over ukraine and we're
just gonna hear more and more um as
ukraine takes back areas and more and
more as russia continues to attack the
eastern part of ukraine luhans danietz
i mean it's it's coming and there are a
major offense that will be launched over
the next week i believe um so there's
it's going to get worse before it can
get better and regarding president
biden's statements unfortunately i think
those statements are empty empty threats
i agree with him in that president that
putin is a war criminal and that we need
international tribunals and stuff but
there's no international police force
that's going to go into russia and
arrest vladimir putin vlad vladimir
putin never leaves russia he will never
be held accountable the only way he'll
be held accountable
is if one there's an internal coup an
uprising that takes him out or two if an
international arrest warrant is issued
and he's dumb enough to fly to a country
that's willing to enforce it but even
then i doubt that you'd have um interpol
or um what or a country's forces go
through russian security and try to
arrest vladimir putin as he's visiting i
mean that that just in my opinion would
be in an act of war in and of itself so
you're never going to see accountability
for putin
uh you know that that that is
unfortunate that um you know because i
actually don't see them you know
wrestling putin for war crimes i mean
they could even uh try and convict him
in some sort of international court i
guess but the actual rest of him won't
come until um putin decides to hold up
in a bunker or
eat an ammo sandwich as it may be um you
know i mean i i think ultimately that's
where this is leading because we've seen
vladimir putin act really irrationally
delusional um and some have said he's
sick some have said there's a lot of
rumors going around about vladimir putin
but there's one thing for sure there's
one thing for sure that this guy was
definitely not prepared um to launch the
offensive and the aggression that he
launched against ukraine
and i i believe that's one of the things
that um
kind of surprised the international
community that russia wasn't as prepared
to for the aggression that they wanted
and the war crimes that they wanted to
commit on ukraine that ukrainians have
stood for their country now they've been
patriots and they fought for their
democracy even as flimsy as that
democracy may seem they definitely want
to fight for it
yeah no i i fully agree with you i mean
i think that
russia really was unprepared for two
reasons one was the fact that ukrainian
resistance as you noted i was going to
be strong but also too is that russian
morale is really at an all-time low
right now many of these russian forces
are being sent into a country where many
of their brothers sisters family members
live people that they communicate with
every day they share a language
practically they share um the same
cultures the same food
they share
a lot of similarities because ukraine
was part of the soviet union just 20 25
years ago um and many of these soldiers
when they're coming in they're not being
told what they're going to fight for
when they're and when they are told by
their commanders and by the generals hey
you're going to go kill your brothers or
your sisters
they're obviously they obviously step
back and say no and we we have more
reports every single day of russian
commanders of russian troops saying no
i'm not fighting surrendering to
ukrainian forces or just simply
rebelling against their orders
and we're going to see more and more of
this in the coming days but i will say
this um now that putin's re-kind of
regrouped and reorganized i do believe
that he'll likely learn from his past
mistakes i think the offense if he'll
launch in the next week or so will be a
lot stronger and
may actually be successful in taking
eastern ukraine and even parts of
southern ukraine so we'll see um for his
sake he better hope that he learned his
lesson because if he didn't he'll be out
of power very soon
you know that that's a good point and
and the way you explained it kind of
reminds me of history um during the
second world war the uh
churchill encouraged the americans to go
up through italy into europe to take
germany uh nazi germany and when when
the americans arrived in italy there was
a lot of italian-americans
who arrived there as american soldiers
and when they got there it was their
families who were there who were waiting
for them not not some kind of evil
fascist regime that was going to kill
american soldiers but it was their
uncles their aunts their brothers their
sisters because these american soldiers
that were fighting were
americans and they were from their
family was from
italy um so it kind of harkens back to
history and um i think that's one thing
that delusional leaders especially
murderous dictators like vladimir putin
fail to recognize is that history is is
easily repeated and if you pay attention
um you can you can help from repeating
it if you just don't do really stupid
dumb things and like uh have an
aggression on ukraine and murder
innocent women children and men in
ukraine
because they're going to fight for their
country it is a democracy and speaking
of democracies and fighting for them
before you go i do want to ask you
because i know you're
you're very very well versed and not
just ukrainian politics and russian
politics but also american politics you
tweet about it all the time everyone go
follow aaron on twitter i i so like his
tweets we we feature his tweets on the
show every once in a while here on the
[ __ ] list roundup but aaron
um
it really is very strange to watch
our politics in this country for one
party and one party only to try to tear
down a democracy the way that putin has
tried all around the world and with some
of these bills that are happening inside
the republican party the way that they
the other day it was very
strange to watch
the republican senators in the judiciary
committee talk highly of
judge brown jackson and then say all in
the same breath there's no way i can
support her
and it's it's this it's this real bad
stench of putin-style fascist politics
what's your take on this
yeah i mean when it comes to judge
jackson she is honestly in my opinion
the most qualified judge in the entire
country um like i don't i can't think of
a republican or i mean conservative or
liberal judge that is more qualified
than judge jackson to be on the court
and many of these republican senators
knew this because in 2008 about two
years ago they voted for a confirmation
to the dc circuit they also voted for
confirmations the dc district court
lindsey graham won being one of those
senators they knew this which is why
they supported her
any any games now they're playing are
purely political they're not they're
just trying to score political points
and advance the midterms try to they're
in my opinion they're really testing
their arguments for the midterms right
now in these hearings and just generally
um so you're going to see some crazy
things come out from the republican
party
like we saw the other day yesterday i'm
in oklahoma with the first bill in the
country to totally ban abortion like we
saw in tennessee the bill that
essentially removed age requirements for
marriage and removed
forced marriage provisions um in
tennessee law or the one that wants to
at least um we're you're going to see
more and more in ohio you had a don't
say gay bill introduced yesterday just
after florida passed they don't say gay
bill uh two weeks ago or three weeks ago
now so
the republican party is shifting more
right and is going more radical and is
going to make a lot of noise and it's
important for democrats to stand up it's
important for democrats to fight back
and call it call them out every chance
we get but also at the same time to
recognize that
we can't just call out their bad policy
we have to promote good policy and if
we're not getting anything done in
congress if we're not passing bill back
better we shouldn't expect to win this
year or really ever
because we can't just fight against
republicans we have to promote good
democratic policies
you know i'm glad you brought up you say
it was ohio that had uh just introduced
it don't say bill i'm glad you brought
that up because democrats need to
recognize something and i talk about it
a lot here on the show and and you
probably agree with me on this there's
two things at play here there is there
is politics and there is government
right these are two separate things
these things actually do not have
anything to do with each other what i
mean by that is in in florida uh
republicans won the policy fight and
uh ron desantis that scumbag actually
signed the don't say gay bill into law
now rather it'll stand or whatever it's
still law today um so they won the
policy fight but i believe they really
did lose the messaging fight what i mean
by that is the number one complaint the
thing that they're complaining about the
most and i mean the extreme right wing
is that it doesn't say don't say gay in
that bill it doesn't say that it doesn't
say that it doesn't read the bill read
the bill look at the line items in the
bill and i think i think liberals and
democrats in this country really
don't see
the actual power of that messaging that
hey if you if you want to make sure we
don't have don't say gay bills in states
of ohio or florida or texas or
wherever they want to out florida
florida as i say um
wherever they want to do that in our
country what we have to do is we have to
have reasonable pro-democracy people
in place in government to make those
policy decisions and when i say
pro-democracy the problem is right now
that we have is there's only one party
only one that is pro-democracy and
pro-liberty and that's the challenge so
how how do we in these midterms do you
think can we use the don't say gay
messaging can we use the messaging
against these republicans for these laws
that are coming out of the out of
tennessee to basically put them on the
defensive um and and and and put them in
a position where they have to defend
these diabolical really vile policies
unfortunately um probably not and the
reason no because i think the average
everyday american doesn't really care
about don't say gable they care about
their gas prices they care about
inflation rates they care about the
money that's coming into their bank
accounts and if gas prices are at six
dollars a gallon um in some of these
areas come november i think it's going
to be a very bad year for democrats even
if and even if people recognize which it
needs to be recognized that joe biden
and democrats are not at fault for gas
prices increasing but if inflation is
still as high as as high as it is right
now
it's going to be a bad year for
democrats um so that's what we need to
focus on we need to focus on the meat
and potatoes issues that get
every day average americans excited
that's gas prices that's inflation rates
economic uh economic impact on people's
pockets and people's wallets um
and then at everything else we can use
as attack ads like the don't say gay and
like um
like abortion things like that what
republicans are pushing but many of
those attacks are going towards
single-issue voters um single-issue
voters who focus who are either pro-life
or pro-choice single-issue voters who
care about the lgbtq community um as
their number one choice um the average
democratic voter in middle of america is
caring about their money not necessarily
abortion rights or don't say gay bill so
we need to focus on the meat and
potatoes issues and not necessarily on
these um inflammatory um
social bills that are being pushed by
the republican party we can
we can combat those when we're in the
legislature when we're in congress but
we need to show them not just why
they're bad but why we're good um and if
we're putting more money in your pocket
at the end of the day you're going to
vote for us so that's the ultimate goal
well i i tend to agree with you on on a
bit of that but i want to push back a
bit because i think i think that there
are people out there in this country who
are worried about gas prices who are
worried about inflation and the reason
why they're worried about it is because
they've been sold a bill of goods that
are lies at the water cooler right um
and they and they bought it because it's
easier to buy it's easier to buy what
joe says at work than to actually you
know figure out that it's corporate oil
companies that are gouging you right
that it's corporations that are causing
part of this inflation problem by
gouging you um because they can because
the narrative is is that the economy's
uh the inflation's bad uh we've seen the
fed uh going to make some moves with
interest rates which um actually helps
the rich in this country it doesn't hurt
them and a lot of people don't
understand that that inflation inflation
as as bad as it may be is really good
for businesses and really good for rich
people like they love inflation they
love inflation and that's why that's why
they want you to be so discouraged about
inflation is because it's good for them
especially when you're blaming it on
someone who it's not their the fault of
which is the present united states but
it's its corporation's fault and to some
degree some degree it is the economy
it's the natural state of of how it's
heating up but i do want to push back
with on you
just a bit aaron because i want to
challenge you a bit on these issues like
don't say gay and some of these
pedophile bills that they're actually
that they're actually passing because i
would say even americans who are
concerned about gas prices who concern
about their grocery prices who are
concerned about their their inflation
i believe that they're concerned about
their children not just not just their
children's minds and their education
because we've seen all around the
country that the crt voodoo types are
losing in these school board races
um because they're just
people do not want the wackadoos in
control of their children's minds and
their education
i believe that they will have the same
feeling feeling if they know that there
is one party in this country one party
who is trying to sexualize children's
gender and he was trying to marry them i
believe that that will be important to
those people just as important as gas
prices or inflation or their grocery
prices i believe people love their
children and they will they will want to
make sure they protect them at all cost
not just their minds with their
education but also with their bodies and
their autonomy and their liberty
so what do you say when i tell you
that hey i think gas prices are
important but children's safety and
protection is just as important what do
you think those americans would say so i
i agree with you in in that general
premise but i will say this is that
that's a very reactive argument it's a
very their bad argument that those
they're passing are bad okay great we
all agree on that general premise but
what are we going to do that's good what
are we going to do to protect your
children what are we going to do to
ensure that your children can afford a
better quality of life than we have are
we going to eliminate student loan debt
are we going to reduce student loan debt
are we going to focus on revamping your
child your child's education by
providing better opportunities and
better quality of education for in
public education in public schools are
we going to do that if the answer is yes
then we'll win if the answer is no or if
the answer is we're just going to face
gridlock then we're going to lose
because we could only say
x is so bad long enough because we need
proactive arguments not just reactive
messaging i mean we saw that in virginia
we saw that in um well we almost saw
that in 2020 where if your whole message
is trump is bad
you're going to lose the 2020 election
was a lot closer than it should have
ever been and in my opinion had covenant
and had coveted never existed donald
trump would have actually won that
election because our messaging was so
poor um all we were doing is trump is
bad trump is bad we did that in virginia
trump is bad we did that in virginia
when they were saying we're gonna pass
critical race theory and we're just
saying no we're not doing critical race
here we're not doing critical rates here
don't worry don't worry don't worry well
look how it turned out for us what did
we do to promote public education what
did we do to promote our educational
policy in virginia nothing
so if we're not showing proactive
messaging we're going to lose um that's
just the fact of the matter
so so i agree with you on a couple
things but the one thing i will say is i
didn't say trump in any of that right my
argument was i never said the word trump
in any of my arguments and i think i
think you're right there that you can
actually make all republicans and all
gop politics trump without saying the
word trump sure see and i think that's
the messaging problem because i think me
and you are saying both the same things
it's just what are the words that we are
going to use to do both of those things
right because i think that's one thing
that democrats liberals in this country
really lack
is the kahunes as you you know one might
say
to really to really dig in and not be
scared to say crazy ridiculous things
which we do on this show i you know i
i'm kind of a provocateur i like to say
crazy ridiculous things but i like to
frame it up in a way that has a certain
name so um i think we're i think we're
on the same page here and i think
now is the time to fight this battle of
politics and the election for our
country for our democracy and for our
children and for our gas prices so i
agree with you i agree with you aaron uh
we just need to we i want to have you
back on the show maybe we can talk more
about american politics not just yeah no
ukrainian russian power tony i i fully
agree i'd love to come back on and and i
will just say this imagine instead of
just us saying don't say gay is bad
imagine if we say
democrats support increasing teacher pay
republicans support sexualizing your
children right imagine we do that
message right where we have a positive
proactive message right while also
combating their their negative messaging
um if we do both that's when we'll win
that's that's why i like um because i'm
trying to get this phrasing right that's
why like they're trying to sexualize
your children's gender
and they're trying to marry them um you
know so maybe maybe i can figure out a
way to get gas prices and inflation in
that little message there so i
appreciate you joining us aaron as
always um come back next week any week
uh just let me know if you have
something that you want to talk about
we'll bring you on good
everyone says hi in the in the comments
hi everyone they love aaron so go follow
aaron on twitter the tiki talks and the
instagrams he is on all the social
medias um thank you aaron for joining us
everyone stick around we'll be right
back after this message
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50 a day
you can help us help those true
americans recover from biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those trump
supporters and this is that moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around after the
break
we got even a whole another hour and
plus
coming at you
here on youtube twitter twitch and now
on the midas touch facebook page as you
know
every single week day monday through
friday we are live
oh i still have seen see i'm you know
i can do this yeah i still got aaron's
banner up here
worthless worthless this guy is
i'm the only one running the show right
now as we currently speak today just me
so it's all on me
it's all on me today i think gabe is
going to join us here in just a little
bit
um and we're going to talk about a few
things
but i i really enjoy having aaron on i
enjoy having his uh updates on ukraine
and russia so we we get the lowdown he
really keeps an eye on those things um
please if you're on tic tac go follow
him on tic tac he does a lot of tic tac
videos if you follow him on twitter he
talks about ukraine uh russian politics
and
um also american politics on his twitter
page so go follow that he's also the the
host of zoomed in
with the midas touch network the podcast
so go go go check that out he's a
co-host over there
and they talk a lot a lot about american
politics each week
he's on the midas touch network as we
are too you know
you know that we broadcast from the
minus touch facebook page
thank you all of you out there who are
new listeners on facebook don't forget
to go over to the youtube channel
just search tony michael's podcast and
subscribe to our youtube channel that's
where it's at over there that way if you
want to go watch it on youtube you have
the ability to go re-watch on youtube we
also post my tiki talks that i do um we
also post some other things over there
and follow us on instagram give us a
like thumbs up
on facebook youtube
i know i don't know if you can give
thumbs up on on twitch you put in a
comment i guess
give us some comments retweet that
retweet this [ __ ] on twitter
you know we love the the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
as always
we're kind of fans of twitter here i
don't know
maybe that's wrong maybe that's right
it's kind of my favorite social media
platform
because i get to type in anything i want
and now that elon musk is going to be
the dictator of
twitter this is kind of ridiculous
everyone's freaking out because
uh
elon musk bought his spot on the board i
think he's somehow going to be like the
dictator of twitter like he can just
wave a magic wand and donald trump's
gonna be back on the platform which you
know i'm not saying i would or wouldn't
like to have donald trump back on the
platform i have a lot of mixed feelings
about it i really want to tweet at him
to be honest with you but you know
that's just me
you know and
but elon musk elon musk does not have a
magic wand
but i would say
that
really crazy people are going to be able
to say really crazy things if he does
have any kind of power
over the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends speaking of the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends how about because we
do have a lot of [ __ ] to round up today
you know we have a lot of trash
to put in the garbage
today we have deutsche bank
uh going on uh
we have a lot of stuff here we have
russian banks we have cpac tom cotton
has been trending so is sean hannity
there's a lot of garbage to put in the
trash so let's start the countdown let's
go to the tweety tweets and attorney
trends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends on the [ __ ]
list roundup
um
people are telling me to check my dms
what's going on in the dms
what's going on over there
let's see
all right
i don't see the uh that i don't see the
dm you're talking about
all right
let's get to the tweety tweets and
listen to robin see they keep saying and
check my dms check my dmc see this is
what happens
um she said robin says please check her
dms
um is it the show dms or my personal
dm's
dm last night oh oh let's let's see
let's see
oh
is this is this the uh um
is this the the court thing which is
sheldon winehouse is that what you're
talking about robin
is that where you want me to go is to
the sheldon winehouse
the sheldon whitehouse video
okay let's go to the tweets and training
turns let's go to the timeline here and
we'll figure this situation out
with the dm
okay uh you know there's a lot of um
let the women run my show yep well i i
keep telling you i keep telling you that
women should run things i'm not saying
i'm not saying that they should or they
shouldn't but they definitely should be
running my show um there's a couple
things um here on the tweet tweets and
trendy trends i think the one thing that
robin is wanting me to get to
is a video that sheldon winehouse did um
and christopher has it tweeted here let
me let me make this a little bigger yep
fun fact christopher says let's make it
bigger fun fact the katanji brown
jackson confirmation hearing that is
really going to piss you off republican
senators didn't research or fact fine to
decide which questions to ask are
hearing swamp quote unquote dark money
groups fed them the talking points here
is
here is the concord fund
here is
senator sheldon whitehouse
who has made a lot of arguments against
the federal society buying
supreme court justice seats
on the court for republican nominations
you remember
uh when trump ran in 2016 right
he doesn't listen to nobody he's not
he's not bound by anyone or anything
right he does whatever the [ __ ] he wants
unless
unless the federalist society buys you
right the federal society buys trump's
campaign and forces him to say well i'll
listen to whatever the federalist
society will tell me whatever they tell
me i'll do it right well that's i mean
his whole [ __ ] life
but let's listen to what sheldon
winehouse says here about kbj and some
of the nominations but more importantly
the questions that were asked by
republican senators so where does it
turn out that all this judicial
philosophy talk we heard the word 50
times in the hearings it comes from a
little group
of groups that all share the same
address it's called independent women's
forum independent women's voice
independent women's law center
it's uh
very attached to leonard leo who's done
all the
isn't that funny
all these women's group
they're all attached to a man
oh jesus these right wingers they just
can't help themselves they can't help
themselves judge picking
and his pair of front groups 85 fund and
concord fund which are funded by the
kochs and their foundations and the
bradley foundation and it was run by a
coke lobbyist for years
while she also ran
americans for prosperity the big koch
brothers political mothership
and surprise surprise
in one of these organizations you will
find none other than senator hawley's
spouse working what
wait a second you mean josh hawley's
wife
works for the people who pick the
supreme court justices come on
surely not
and they
directed everyone actually before
before judge jackson was even named
it is important you focus not on the
selection process or on the nominees
paper qualifications but rather on the
need to learn more about the nominees
and this is italics and bold judicial
philosophy judicial philosophy well we
heard that over and over and over again
when they complained that they couldn't
question judge brown jackson about
sexual assault allegations against her
because there are none
remember lindsey graham josh i will we
can't question you about sexual assault
allegations it's unfair that we had to
question brett kavanaugh because he was
accused of sexual assault but we can't
question you because you're not accused
of sexual assault that's why you can't
ask her you dumb [ __ ]
but here sheldon winehouse
is pulling out the stops showing you the
evidence and it wasn't josh hawley ted
cruz tom cotton mike lee
chuck grassley coming up with these
talking points you think those brain
dead [ __ ] who were going to
cocaine-fueled orgies
who are who are trying to make sure they
write up don't say gay bills and
supporting gop pedophile bills and
states you think they have time to
research
judge brown jackson [ __ ] no
they got a lot other kind of nazi type
[ __ ] that they're trying to do
they can't be they can't be focusing on
research
of what
kbj's political philosophy quote unquote
would be
lines
lines fed to them these pieces of [ __ ]
so
that comes straight out of swamp
dark money talking points yeah and you
see the same thing with the sexual
predators uh angle on her um child
pornography sentencing
so this brings us to the [ __ ]
pedophile child porn obsession that
these republicans have the projection
that they have
uh again you you remember josh holly and
ted cruz
couldn't help but focus on that judge
brown jackson was a confirmed federal
judge
who
sentenced criminals who were charged
indicted and convicted
of pornography child pornography
pedophilia child molesting and she's the
federal judge who was assigned
by the court
to sentence these criminals like that's
what a [ __ ] judge does you [ __ ]
idiots
but they're so concerned that judge
brown jackson would sentence child
pornographers like so are you are you
really concerned
that she's sentencing them or that these
child pornographers were caught because
it really does seem like you're on
you're you're starting to be on the side
of
a pedophiles kid diddlers and child
pornographers
you're really obsessed with it it's
really weird but let's listen to sheldon
whitehouse where they got these
arguments that came out of another
front group
uh with all sorts of creepy ties
including the legendary cleta mitchell
oh yeah and uh the guy who runs that one
was ted cruz's oppo guy and cruz for
president oh
so ted cruz
ted cruz and his staff
are running the operation of who's
obsessed with child pornography
obsessed with it obsessed that how dare
kbj sentence a child pornographer how
dare she
how dare she do that just like they
accuse brett kavanaugh
sexual misconduct because there was
credible allegations against him
jesus christ you can't make this [ __ ] up
so you've got holly and cruz who are
saying these things with like family
members and staff
feeding stuff to them from these dark
money groups the swamp as it were we
need to drain the swamp i think i think
all i think i think they were right we
need to drain the swamp they just didn't
know what the [ __ ] the swamp was
jesus christ so where
thank you for for pointing that video
out
to us uh let's go back up the timeline
here uh because
uh joe walsh and tucker carlson are in a
uh a twitter
a twitter battle
i'm not even going to go there
joe said earlier if ted cruz and josh
holly had a baby it would be tom cotton
uh here was my response here was my
response my response was and republican
kid dealers
would want to marry it they'd want to
marry that kid for sure 100 percent for
sure they'd want to marry that baby
uh rachel bitkoffer
tweets earlier a
an image
of steve kornacki in front of his famous
board talking about the white house
party in midterm elections and what the
history is
now rachel says the midterm effect is
coming it can't be reasoned away
it doesn't magically change our race
dems have no idea how to blunt it
but i do
[Laughter]
i i see i see rachel don't you we have
rachel a bit of golfer on here every
once while doc as some people call her
doc bittikoffer i can see her giving
this evil at me
can't you and evil uh thank you thank
you rachel again for your for your
insight i hope i hope we can get more
and more democratic campaigns to listen
to doc bittic offer rachel if you're out
there
yell and scream yell and scream
uh let me ask you a question i tweeted
this earlier
because i think this is important
if i can get the damn thing to work
right there we go sorry my zoom is not
working it's not you know every once in
a while it just doesn't work correctly
but now we got it here i posed a
question earlier on twitter maybe you
can answer it would you let a trump
republican babysit your kid
would you would you let a trump
republican babysit your kid at this
point
they can't they're obsessing over
childborn
they can't help but sexualize children's
gender
and they want to marry them
this is really weird [ __ ]
really weird [ __ ] and i it is surprising
you know me and aaron were talking about
gas prices
but do you really think americans aren't
going to pay attention
when republicans are passing pedophile
bills so they can marry people's
children
do you really think that
jesus christ okay
did it
a hill reporter has a as an article
watch devin nunes claims troubled true
social is getting massive engagement
they can't even get people onboarded
onto the goddamn site how does it have
any engagement get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
um here's a video from james longman we
were talking about um
some of the stuff going on in ukraine
and russia um this is a very good report
um these uh from abc and and james
longman let's listen in here for a
minute nikola was forced to live in the
basement of his apartment building as
russian soldiers moved in and when they
arrived the horror began
they made all the men go outside and
check their papers he tells me and if
they found anything they didn't like
they would shoot them immediately and
not ask any questions he says the
russians shot everyone under the age of
50.
you're 53. exactly so you made it by
three years
yeah it's crazy that's crazy uh you go
watch this full video
i retweet it and there's also a really
good thread um from bucha that james put
up um
just about yesterday so go go um go
check that out as here's reporting in
bucha walking through bucha and the war
crimes that were committed there um
again the threat is right below the
video on the timeline so go go check
that out
it is a
crazy crazy thread okay
someone tweeted earlier
uh
uh
gross
old pedophiles gop stands for gross old
pedophiles
oh
boy oh boy oh boy that was in response
to my tweet which i tweeted earlier
the republican kid diddlers want to
sexualize your kid's gender
and marry them in any age
got it the republican kid diddlers
want to sexualize your children's gender
and marry them at any age
that's what they're doing
they're doing it all around the country
they want to take your kids gender and
make it sexual somehow gender i i can't
even believe
i can't believe we have to we have to do
this we have to [ __ ] be dictionary
for these dumb [ __ ]
seriously we gotta be dictionary.com for
these [ __ ] this is absolutely
ridiculous
look just because the word gender and
the word sex
share a similar definition does not mean
gender
is sexualized it's only sexualized
because you're [ __ ] weirdos
just because you're a girl a boy a man a
woman whatever trans man trans woman
if if you're a gay man
a gay woman it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't matter you dumb [ __ ] if
you identify as they and them
she
he whatever
whatever
gender
is not sexualized you're making it
sexualized you [ __ ] weirdos it's the
same crazy ass [ __ ] that you do about
genitalia and bathrooms
same crazy stuff they make genitalia in
bathrooms sexualized
i have never in my [ __ ] life went
into a public bathroom and was concerned
about the genitalia the person next to
me or in the bathroom in general
not i wasn't concerned at all about
their genitalia
and
it's probably because i'm not a [ __ ]
weirdo
you [ __ ] weirdos are absolutely
obsessed
with people's gender
and sexualizing their gender
genitalia
and marrying any genitalia no matter
what age it is
it's [ __ ] gross
it needs to stop because they're not
going to stop there they're not going to
stop at just oh well we can marry
we can marry at any age
we can marry at any age we can marry him
in any age they're going to start to
tell you that they can marry your
children without your consent
the people in power are going to say
they have the consent to marry whoever
they want
doubt me
did you have it on your bingo card 10
years ago 2012 think about this
2012 after mitt romney lost did you have
it on your [ __ ] bingo card that 10
years later
we would be talking
about how the republican party is trying
to pass bills in states where they can
marry babies
it's what they're doing
like right now as we speak this isn't
like hyperbole i'm not saying oh they're
gonna try they're doing it right now
right now we have we have uh the gabe
sanchez our co-host and executive
producer joining us gabe how's that mike
working today uh pretty good odds for
perfect perfect absolutely that's great
i hear you're talking about the uh the
grand old pedophiles yes the grand old
pedophiles i i called them uh republican
kid diddlers this morning
i mean it's not wrong why well i mean uh
i think it's an actual it's got a real
good ring to it i think it's a phrase
that we can actually
uh
really push out there i think people
understand what it means um the nice
part about the word diddler is people
get the idea
but the definition just like republicans
like to use certain words like whacker
that's right that's right that's right
so i think republican kid diddler is
perfect
to frame up these morons because that's
really what they're wanting to do is
they're wanting to ditto kids
it's absolutely ridiculous yeah i mean
yeah it it's disgusting yeah right let's
just call what it is [ __ ] gross for
for a uh for a group of people that you
know i think i said it the other day
which is like you know
the whole like save our children it save
our children from the gqp save our
children from the grand old pedophiles
and these pedophiles these republican
members of
of the legislator
are putting in place what would be legal
for you to to to be a pedophile right
like for so for a group of people who
say like oh don't sexualize this don't
talk about this you know we want to
restrict this so kids don't get
indoctrinated with the woke liberalism
or whatever meanwhile over here that's
like i'm about to marry this kid and you
can't do anything about it and that is
incredibly [ __ ] up and for anyone of
that party to just look at that and be
like yeah there's nothing wrong with
this like that's like even if you were
to take the like even if you were to
look at it and say like
matt gates it's an allegation okay fine
we'll say that but if you have a party
literally putting into law that you can
now just marry anyone of any age
children
and say
yeah that sounds good it's like well
then what the [ __ ] is wrong with you but
this is how fascism
slow creeps right because they've been
saying all kinds of crazy ass [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] about democrats for like six
years like six years they say this stuff
like oh they're pedophiles and the
child's sucking cabal and a pizza place
in washington and all kinds of weird ass
funky [ __ ]
and the reason why is because they want
to normalize that kind of talk with
their base because that way when they go
ahead and they introduce bills like well
the democrats do it why can't we
right it's i mean it's they're trying to
normalize it right don't you think no
complete i think they're you know
they're trying to get it into the the
normal like lexicon that is right our
like day-to-day language and also
they're you know they're projecting
their own you know wants and desires for
the same reason they're like oh well you
know these gay people shouldn't do this
or these trans people shouldn't do this
it's like no maybe you're speaking about
something inside maybe you feel a
certain way and the party you're a part
of you can actually be your true self
and as a result you have to project your
your uh
uh your your your uh just
unwanted approval or whatever uh on to
the on to this group a group that is not
even affecting you a group that is not
entering your lives not not not berating
you not walking in your home and telling
you what you should do not
indoctrinating you on what you should
believe or who you should be or whatever
they're just saying hey
we feel away and this is how we feel the
most comfortable to be
there is no right that you have as a
republican party to tell anyone
of any any background or you know what
it's like
why is this not you know a protected
right because that's what it is right it
is it is something that should be or you
know should be protected right they
fought us hard
on
uh allowing same-sex marriage and you
know what it's now they're like okay
well that's like common it's not as
extreme as where we need to bring it
because that's what the right does they
take it and they take it to the extreme
and they're saying before was like oh
same-sex marriage we can't do that what
are they gonna marry robots and dogs now
now i'm not saying that the republicans
are into that type of stuff but i
wouldn't be surprised right
well i i mean here's the thing we've
seen just a couple weeks ago the senator
from indiana sitting senator from
indiana basically advocate for states
passing laws to where you can't have
interracial marriage interracial
marriage not not same-sex marriage i
mean we're talking we're talking about
taking the clock back 50 years but with
this with this gop pedophile bill in
tennessee they really want to kick the
clock back several hundred years because
i don't think they're gonna stop there
because we're gonna have we're gonna
have florida try to out tennessee
tennessee we're gonna have texas try it
out florida florida and eventually what
we're gonna have is a bill that says
powerful white men can take your
children and marry them without your
consent i mean i
don't don't get it [ __ ] twisted
because again
10 years ago there's no way anyone had
on their bingo card that the republican
party of mitt romney
that just lost the the presidential race
would be passing bills in states
that would say you can marry a child at
any age any age not not just like like
because currently the agents in in
tennessee for consent is 17 right that's
the current age um which is not an adult
i mean i guess it's kind of an adult
because you're giving consent to be
married right which it should be
probably changed to 18. it's probably
what it should be changing i think the
same rule exists in illinois and uh
california where there's several
statutory rape right right there's
several there's several states that that
set it at 17 and you're right it's
because of the statutory rape um
statutes that live in those states
but listen if that's if that's the case
if that's the argument that you're
trying to make for 17 versus 18
the gop pedophiles in tennessee
they want to make it to where
an infant is not
statutory rape
they want to make it to where a
three-year-old the four-year-old a
12-year-old is not statutory rape this
is [ __ ] vile disgusting and they are
they are they are
with legislation
attacking
attacking not just the minds of our
children but the bodies of our children
and that that to me is the most
disgusting part um of all of this and
they're not going to stop here they're
not going to stop they're not going to
this isn't like oh
this is where this is our last you know
they're our last thing right right like
we're not i mean i can open i mean you
got it yeah sorry well i mean in
oklahoma there there is no there were no
abortion clinics in oklahoma you know
what they did in oklahoma they're like
you know what since there's no abortion
we're going to even go a step further
we're even going to go a step further
and take away someone who has a uterus
their entire liberty over their body
their entire liberty over their body
even though you can't even you can't
even hardly get an abortion in oklahoma
we're still gonna take it away from you
so if you think
if you think they're gonna stop
at just you giving consent for your
children and not making it to where they
can take consent from your for your
children you are out of your mind they
are coming for it and they are they are
coming for it today and they are on our
doorstep and they are coming at you hard
and the only way we stop them the only
way that we stop them is to participate
in our democracy and make sure that we
message correctly and we make sure that
we get pro-democracy people who are in
those seats and the only party that is
pro-democracy right now that isn't
running rampant with this with this kid
diddler stuff
is democrats because republicans are kid
diddlers it's weird it's i just i i mean
you got to look at it like like i i
would hope that you know i'd be like oh
hope everyone wakes up but literally
like if you watch what's happening you
got republicans saying that you can uh
the the actual sex offenders the the
predators of uh rape and assault you
know can actually sue families right
there's that one then you've got this
thing that says ectopic uh pregnancies
are illegal then you've got this example
in indiana about interracial marriage is
legal then you got this situation in uh
in tennessee where they're saying now
you can marry children of any age right
doesn't have to be 17 it can be way
younger you like them young even better
then you got this whole thing about how
abortions are illegal like you see this
trend moving further and further to just
group everything where basically it's
like who you can marry you can marry
anyone of any age younger the better you
can marry anyone in as long as they're
white and if you got someone pregnant
you can sue their ass
uh
regardless of the situation and also you
have to force the woman to have the baby
like you can't stop and look at this and
say oh yeah there's nothing wrong with
any of this
like you have to look at this and say
like this is 100 percent [ __ ] up on
all scales for everything that they're
doing it's just further and further
going against a woman going against
anyone who is a person of color going
against anyone else who is not white and
who is not a man because that's what
it's coming down to
rich powerful white old ass man wants to
do whatever the [ __ ] he wants marry
whoever he wants however old he wants
and the repercussions and and the result
not his problem if anything he'll try to
make money off it by suing the woman
so it's the gqp is a disgusting vile
piece of [ __ ]
right well you know we had aaron on to
talk about ukraine but we also were
debating a little bit back and forth me
and aaron about messaging because he
thinks gas prices and inflation are
going to be the
uh what people are going to vote on and
i actually believe that
people's
people's children's
safety of their minds and their bodies
is just as important if not more than
important than any [ __ ] amount that
they're going to pay at the pump on the
on gas i think that's a that that i mean
i think both both are true i think you
know if it's if it's trivial kind of uh
flash in the pan type topics it's going
to be gasoline and inflation right as
the as the economy grows and
unemployment drops down that's going to
be something that's like right now
problem uh but if we talk long term what
actually is put into law i think you
have a solid point of like saying if if
for the same reason what was that ad
that was done um
was her name daisy what was the ad uh
they did about the nuclear bomb and it
was like do you want to live in a world
where it was like there were it was a
little girl picking daisies it was 19 oh
yeah yeah it's a gold water right right
yeah exactly so that ad right there was
like oh you're you're now thinking my
child right they shouldn't live in this
world right so like if you are able to
fix the the message and the narrative
around saying your children are a target
to these people right if you can do that
if the democrats can actively push on a
solid marketing front to be like the
actual problem is the sick disgusting
vile pedophiles that are from the
republican side the gas yeah sure that's
a problem but that's like a bigger scale
issue that that isn't only a biden thing
right you know the inflation like we're
working on it based on we just got out
of [ __ ] recovery and or uh uh a
pandemic and a bit of a recession here
and had to recover by injecting money
into the economy so we're going to be
you know it's not like a it's going to
happen overnight and fix it like that's
going to take a little bit of time but
if you really go for the long-term plan
which is these old white rich white guys
want to marry your daughter and she's
not even one years old like that's that
like you want to obviously go to the
extreme but there's truth
in in this in this well yeah that's what
they're doing it's not it's not like the
republicans are like well we're gonna
pick 14 right they didn't they didn't
and and i don't
i don't know if they thought oh well
we'll be much worse it'll be way worse
if we pick 14 than if we just do away
with the age limit all together like no
doing away with the age of them is way
worse buddy right way worse like you
can't even justify 14. like at that
point you're like right this person
potentially might not be even entering
into puberty or developing but they are
promoting 14 by night peeling away i
mean 12 11 10 you pick the [ __ ] age
they want to marry it right it it
absolutely is [ __ ] weird and in 2022
i think i think that suburban white
voters who are the generic ballot we've
had rachel bid a dr rachel bittikover on
here and she talks a lot about the
generic ballot and for those people out
there that don't understand what the
generic ballot is is it's people who
don't pay attention to politics it's
people who don't have a party
affiliation
it's people who really don't know or
give a [ __ ] much about politics but they
do vote and they vote
based on their emotions and based on
what they're afraid of and let me tell
you something
let me tell you something people in
suburbia
six months from now especially in
november when crude is is likely to be
at a low a very low which means that gas
prices will be down um the fed is
already talking about raising interest
rates which is going to slow in
inflation and back it up and rich people
like corporations and investors are
going to make more money because they
love inflation they're cheering for the
fed to raise interest rates here this is
not like they're like oh this is going
to hurt us nope they've got all the cash
they got all the they got all the
savings they're going to capitalize on
this
but as that starts to tick away what is
left other than the fear to win this
election now i believe and i think you
do too gabe and i think most of our
listeners do is that we can't wait for
gas prices to go down we can't wait for
the inflation to subside
we can talk about both things we can
message both things
and say how the republican party
do you trust
that someone if if the if republic if
politicians control gas prices gabe do
you really trust the people who want to
marry your children with gas
prices not at all i i mean really
honestly i'm not gonna say that they
have a complete uh [ __ ] up reality and
right logical but they do they do have a
complete [ __ ] up and logical reasoning
in their mind where they say i should
marry a kid that seems totally cool i've
always wanted that let's make it legal
that type of person should not be in any
sort of government uh office making
decisions for anyone gas prices
inflation health care anything right the
only people who want that are the people
obviously who want to benefit from that
now obviously you can make that argument
on all sides in terms of lobbying in
different sectors and different things
that are passed in pork and all these
things are in law
but something that's like hey listen
we're going to legalize pedophilia and
you're like
wait what that's like that should be
that is what it is right like that's the
person you want to control your game
right that's that's the person that you
trust
for your child's future and the gas
prices and inflation is that two you
want you want that sick [ __ ]
right that's your idea of good
government that's your idea of good
policy of getting gas prices and
inflation to go away is to put the
person who wants to marry an
eight-year-old girl
in charge of your government okay well
good luck with that that's why i think
we can win this argument folks that's
why i think we can tie these two things
together thank you ken for the super
chat here he says
uh ken says minus lisa for bonehead of
the week i think midas lisa
isn't able to join us for some reason to
me
minus ken and midas lee i think i think
they are husband and wife brother i i'm
not sure exactly they have some sort of
connection here but they really tease
each other in the chat um everyone come
to the chat and check out midaskin and
midas lisa always always going back and
forth the chat is always great on our
show
our our audience doesn't just talk about
the issues they talk to each other in in
the chat um they're informing each other
in the chat making sure and sometimes
they'll send us like new stuff
absolutely well uh uh midas robin sent
me the video sheldon whitehouse um on
lawrence o'donnell's show talking about
dark money the actual swamp in
washington uh actually you know like
trying to buy supreme court justices and
speaking of that because we have tom
cotton and he's trending
this [ __ ] nazi this talk talk about
talk about a talk about a republican kid
diddler here this guy is completely
obsessed with child porn along with his
buddy josh holly i don't know if they
like they have like a a research
quote unquote research uh group that
they do on child porn but boy they
really sure seemed obsessed about it
let's listen to what tom cotton said on
the floor
of the senate during
the supreme court justice nomination of
kbj judge brown jackson you know the
last judge jackson
left the supreme court to go to
nuremberg and prosecute the case against
the nazis
this judge jackson might have gone there
to defend them he is such a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what a vile piece of [ __ ] number one
number one
if you actually believe in the justice
system which he does not clearly he
clearly does not believe in our justice
system in our country he does not
believe in rights he does not believe in
freedom because any reasonable person
would say
yes
someone as vile as tom cotton as
probably the crimes that you could
imagine that tom cotton possibly would
commit if he would commit crimes i'm
speaking hypothetically here right but
if he if this kid diddler this
republican kid diddler
josh holly or excuse me tom i get them
confused it's really confusing i mean
they are they are
right right right they're both nazis and
they're both pedophiles right right or
here
allegedly
allegedly
they are uh
both projecting their own wants and
desires right onto little kids
exactly so tom cotton even even me
um not liking tom cotton at all you can
tell
even me if tom cotton was brought up on
some kind of criminal charges i'm not
saying he's committed crimes i'm just
saying if he were i would want him to
have a defense in that court i would
want that nazi like
like tom cotton i would want him to have
a defense in that court now i would bet
that someone like judge brown jackson
uh
would tell him to get [ __ ] but he
would love
tom cotton would love for someone as
good and qualified as judge brown
jackson to defend his nazi ass in court
that's oh yeah sure
goddamn sure do we know you know uh
speaking of uh
just i just kind of went off on a
tangent here uh only because of scotus
so blackburn
has she said anything
uh as of late about her position on this
tennessee bill oh you mean you mean you
mean uh marsha blackburn the person who
tried to get a one-up on uh george brown
jackson what is a woman here yeah what
is a woman uh she tried she tried that
[ __ ] on uh judge brown jackson has she
come forward about her position on this
tennessee bill since it's her state you
know it would be it would it probably
would not be the most popular position
on the bill i would imagine so i doubt
she's going to make a public statement
and what i mean by the most popular
position is that she would support the
bill to make sure that that
men could could marry little girls
you know i i think she would be for that
at this point i mean she definitely
knows what a woman is for sure
she's got the definition down she looked
it up in the dictionary i guess
yeah
it just it
let's see i just i just haven't heard i
mean i'm you know not to to harp on this
too much but i just haven't heard any
republicans speak out against this bill
let's go to her face or her uh her
twitter page i mean if anyone anyone
who's listening can you if you find
something let us know but i haven't seen
a republican or at least a well uh
uh well-positioned and kind of
well-known republican that actually has
spoken out against this
uh this tennessee uh bill so here is a
supporter of kid diddlers by not saying
anything she's a supporter because she
said i'm honored to serve the people of
tennessee i'm honored to serve the men
who want to marry kids of tennessee
right
the the light the legislator of men who
want to marry little girls in tennessee
um she mentions joe biden here joe biden
joe biden
yeah a lot of bizarre biden
uh uh here oh
here's something that doesn't have joe
biden uh but it does have clinton in it
you know she's obsessed with clinton
black lives matter i'm surprised we
haven't seen where's the hunter binding
line communist oh here here's the hunter
biden's laptop post uh let's see what
else do we have oh here's more hunter
and joe biden
and and chyna here's here's here's her
her her black who black dude who was
president tweet president obama now oh
here's her woke disney china um tweet
here's her cova tweet uh let's see
here's hunt more hunter buttons laptop
um let's see here's biden biden's laptop
china
she has said nothing really
in the last 24 hours that would give her
any any um clue that senator marsha
blackburn is for or against which would
make me think she is four
yeah i just say like if you're silent
then you're complicit yeah probably if
it's your state and you haven't said a
thing about it you're complicit right
probably probably here's the thing
here's the thing [ __ ] marsha blackburn
and [ __ ] anyone who's not out there
as a republican and and i this includes
mitt romney liz cheney adam kinzinger if
these people are not going to say
anything about this bill in tennessee
you are a republican kid diddler
and we should paint them as such and do
you want do you want republican kid
diddlers in charge of your gas prices is
that what you want america
there you go there's how you frame it up
do you want republican kid diddlers in
charge of your gas prices you know what
let's [ __ ] tweet that [ __ ] we're
doing it right now we're doing a tweet
that [ __ ] uh yeah it's just it's insane
that you would say you know what my
representative who supports this illegal
act that i said we should save the
children but really the republican party
is not saving the children because what
they're doing is they're putting those
children in danger they're putting those
children who are developing in danger
of putting them in an environment that
is unsafe right and that's the world
that republicans want to live in but
they you know the white rich white old
guy right they they think that they
have
the ultimate thing the ultimate opinion
the final say whatever they want you
know it's that moment of like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with this republican party
what the [ __ ] is wrong with the gqp
right what what the [ __ ] is wrong with
this group of people who want to make it
legal to marry children right as a
parent not myself but as a parent out
there like i hope that you would look at
this and say
this is 100
[ __ ] up to allow a man to marry a
whoever at any age right
you know they throw up their arms about
same-sex marriage they throw up the
rounds about giving rights to trans
people but you know what they don't
throw out their arms about and rather
that they cheer and support marrying a
kid marrying a child [ __ ] with that
if that doesn't if you cannot stop and
look at that and say
how does this make any sense
because this is completely [ __ ] up
this this is so
asked backwards
that you would ever say
this person in office
who wants this should also be the person
that should make other laws and should
be the one who's
dictating how we uh we deal with gas
prices and inflation like
again these people
are not here
to actually serve you
they are here to serve themselves
despite the fact that they are here to
actually serve us
right like i think you know the mooch
said it when we had him on the show he
was like they work for us that's right
we employ them that's right
it doesn't matter what party it doesn't
matter what politician and it doesn't
matter their views or not there are
right we are their employer we are their
employer um if you want to go check that
mooch interview out go go subscribe to
the youtube channel don't forget to do
that if you're on facebook twitch or
twitter go subscribe to the youtube
channel just search the tony michaels
podcast on youtube and please subscribe
over there uh gabe i think you got to
jump um i i wish you could stick around
though because i'm going to play the
video of matt gatz getting into it with
uh with uh with austin and also i'm i'm
gonna play a special video uh and we're
gonna go to commercial break we're gonna
it's it's the commercial the droop you
remember the droop
but when we come back audience we're
going i'm gonna show you a video
of uh
troy keeping keeping it blue
explaining uh how farts work to spread
knicks so stick around don't don't miss
it we'll be right back thanks gabe we'll
see you soon
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew feed the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us
[Music]
we've seen the droop commercial everyone
likes the droop commercial the mask
um
i don't know if you you guys are
following keep troy blue um he's got a
little different handle on
on twitter but he
he's got a video here let me make it a
little bigger um
if you know anything about that tick
tock troy's over on tic tac this is uh
what is called a reply video someone
gives a comment and the comment is
explain this troy
explain this to us if you're so
brilliant you're liberal
underwear and jeans can't stop a fart
from traveling
how would a mass stop a virus so this
person thinks a fart and a virus are the
exact same thing
let's let troy explain
to this person the difference between
a fart and a virus and virus and let's
let him explain to these uh spread necks
how farts work this is ridiculous that
we have to do this but
it is the internet so let's let's listen
well it's official i've lost all faith
in humanity and those of you that have
been following me for a while know that
this is quite a feat considering the
sheer dumb [ __ ] that i've had to put
up with over the last two years on this
app but this one particularly sent me
over the edge and so here i am standing
in my backyard at night addressing farts
to a complete stranger on the [ __ ]
internet so let me try to lay this out
for you in a way that your clearly like
eight-year-old mind might be able to
understand not all microscopic particles
that you can't see with your eye are
exactly the same size for example
gas particles like oxygen are a hell of
a lot smaller than viruses
that's why you're still able to breathe
when you're wearing the mask because the
microscopic holes in the mask are large
enough for oxygen particles to get
through even though they are able to
stop the coronavirus same principle is
true generally when wearing underwear
and jeans when you fart what you're
smelling when somebody farts is the
methane gas coming off of the fecal
matter okay wait wait wait wait wait i
cannot
this is this is the thing folks this is
the thing
ah this is really the problem that we
have right is that there are
not a large percentage but a large
number of people in this country in
particular that are completely [ __ ] up
just can't [ __ ] understand even
simple [ __ ] physics of how farts work
when you have jeans and underwear on
versus when you don't have them on
this is not rocket science
it's not rocket science at all
but these people
actually believe that if you can fart
through your genes and smell it
then a mask with a virus whether it's
coronavirus the flu or anything else
really honestly there's a good [ __ ]
case to be made for mask other than just
the coronavirus
like there's a good case to be made for
the mask when we have flu season when
people are gathering up
it's probably a really good case for it
so we don't get sick and have to spend a
bunch of money on people who are sick
well let's let troy finish here not the
fecal matter itself the methane gas is
able to make it through the underwear
and jeans even though the underwear and
the jeans are stopping the fecal matter
do a little experiment okay um
the next time you're with one of your
frat brothers and they tell you they
have to fart
put your face right up next to their ass
twice okay this is an experiment we have
to do it a couple of different ways to
prove that it works uh put your face
right up next to their ass
one time while they're wearing jeans and
underwear and the next time when they're
butt ass naked and their bare ass is
right in front of your face then have
them fart on your face see what happens
uh biologically
by a lot
between the time when they fart on you
with jeans on and when they fart on you
with bare ass chances are one of those
two times you're gonna get a pink eye
and it won't be the time when they're
wearing jeans oh my god
okay so the point of this is really
honestly the point of this is is that
do you wonder why do you wonder why
there's people running around the
country thinking that a pedophile bill
an actual pedophile bill in tennessee
they have no oh
that's the party i want to have in
control
these people really don't know how farts
work
these these are adults running around
voting they don't understand how farts
work
holy actual [ __ ]
and they're just they're they're making
decisions on who are going to make
decisions for us
like if our children can get married to
adults
think think about it think about it
we have an education problem in our
country
and it is a serious serious issue that
we have so thank you thank you troy for
um blessing us
with your insight
um and really schooling these rednecks
on how
farts work let's go i'm gonna find the
uh
the video here of
uh
lloyd austin the secretary of defense
absolutely destroying
uh
yeah here it is
the hill had it here let's let's go to
make it a little bigger the hill head
this matt getz and the defense secretary
lloyd austin got into a heated exchange
during the house hearing looking at the
2023 defense budget
so this is a hearing
going through the defense budget for
2023 now this is defense so this is like
the entire budget of defense
so let's
let's listen in uh to the arguments that
matt gatz is gonna make here let's
listen mr secretary i've shared with you
the context the context wasn't better
understand socialism so we can defeat it
the context wasn't learn about it so
that we can offer counter measures the
concept was that it's time for socialism
and the reason i know that's the context
is because the lecture was pulled from a
book written by thomas piketty entitled
time for socialism and and i just can't
help but like notice and so your
question is
i control the time your questions have
been
mr secretary you guys told us that
russia couldn't lose you told us that
the taliban couldn't immediately win and
so i guess i'm wondering what in the 773
billion dollars that you're requesting
today is going to help you make
assessments that are accurate in the
face of so many blown calls
you've you've seen what's in our budget
you've seen how the budget matches the
strategy and so i'll let that speak for
itself well i mean i've also seen that
we're behind the secretary we're behind
in hypersonics we've failed to deter
russia last year what are you doing
we're behind in hypersonics how do you
okay who's the head in hypersonics how
do you how do you how do you how do you
make that assessment i don't know
i make that assessment because china is
yielding hypersonic weapon systems and
we are still developing them i make that
assessment because russia actually
by the way your own people brief us that
we are behind and that china is winning
are you aware of the briefings we get on
hypersonics
i am certainly aware of briefings that
we provide to congress okay so here's
the thing here let's stop right here
because here's the thing
normally normally in a house hearing
because because we do actually want
congress people to actually have
oversight of the department of defense
and their defense budget like that is
the thing we want we want to make sure
that the department of defense and the
federal government as dod and dhs is not
just running wild with their defense
budget right but most of the time we do
not have a congress person who runs the
united states military and dod into the
ground and acts like china north korea
are better
right we don't have that now here's
another point that i want to make and
this is very [ __ ] important
uh secretary austin here was nominated
and confirmed under joe biden right and
he did not start the military
like lloyd austin didn't just
start the military
here's what i mean by that it's not like
when president biden took office he
fired all the military all of them all
the soldiers all the generals
everyone had departed at the department
of defense in the army and the navy he
fired all of them and then hired new
soldiers new officers
new generals new dod officials that's
not what happened
the military that is today
which is the united states military and
unites the united states department of
defense
is the same department of defense
that republicans
under donald trump had control over for
four [ __ ] years
so
if the missiles are whatever weaponry
that matt gatz is bitching about
and acting like america are schlubs
because he's running down the american
military
when he's saying these things
and he's running down his country
and he's running down those soldiers who
fight for our country
and who have valor
because it's the same exact military
it's the same one there isn't a
different military it's the same
military that obama had the same
military that biden that biden now has
that trump had
it's the same one yes yes people retire
people move on now the the current
president gets to pick their
administration and their secretary and
they get to redevelop the entire upper
staff of the administration of dod yes
sure fine that is true
but it's the same army it's the same
military
it's the same dod
okay
now
this is only a tell from republicans of
what they want to do
and how they want to do it and it's not
just with the military
it's with the depart it's with the
the department of state
the state department was absolutely
demolished by trump
all the departments the epa the
education department were demolished
by trump
and that's what they want to do
all around this country not just with
these federal institutions like the
department of defense the the education
the environmental protection agency
they want to dismantle your your
children's school
they want to make it so hard for
teachers who are reasonable who want to
educate children in a way that is
that is education
they want them to get so sick and tired
of all the crt and all the republican
pedophile [ __ ] that they quit
they want them to quit they want the
military to quit they want the epa to
quit they want everyone to quit
because if they break the system
if they break the institution
in this country the democratic
institutions that we have they get to
build them back in their image and in
their name
that's what matt gatz is doing here
that's what fascists do they want you to
quit they want you to give up
they want you to stop fighting because
then the system breaks and then they get
to dictate what that system looks like
on the other side it's not just the
hyper it's all over the world it's in
taiwan where china's last year flew more
sorties than ever before it's north
korea on pace to shatter prior records
the number of missiles that they that
they are testing and so while everyone
else in the world seems to be developing
capabilities and being more strategic we
got time to embrace critical race theory
at west point to embrace socialism at
the national defense university to do
mandatory pronoun training see here it
is here it is here's the here's the
nonsense here's the nonsense matt gatz
is trying to do to convey to all the
military why they should quit why they
should walk away it's all broken it's
broken because you're just talking about
gender and wokeness no
you are talking about gender and
wilderness
you are focused on p sexualizing
people's gender
you are focused on ideology
you met gets are focused on those things
you are now we're going to watch uh
secretary austin here
uh hand him his [ __ ] proverbial ass
but i'm telling you that's what they
want to do they want to discourage you
out there pro-democracy people who are
for democracy who think democracy is the
weapon
to fight inequality to fight inequity
to fight fascism
they want you to not believe in it
it's a putin-style politic
that's what they're doing
they're trying to get you the person who
believes in the institution to question
it because if you think if you think as
a pro-democracy person that it's all
over it's already done there's nothing
you can do about it they're already
going to take over ron desantis already
passed the don't say gay bill they're
going to pass pedophile bills all around
the country they're going to marry our
children they're going to destroy our
schools it's over
then it's already done if you decide
that
if you as a pro-democracy person decide
that then it is all over
but
if you as a pro-democracy person do not
buy into this nonsense this [ __ ]
this this
absolute [ __ ] garbage that this
fascist this accused child sex
trafficker
who is sitting on a committee by the way
which is [ __ ] disgusting i'm sure he
loves the bill in tennessee
he loves the pedophile bill in tennessee
why wouldn't why wouldn't why wouldn't
matt gast love the gop
kid diddlers and their bill in tennessee
i mean god damn he would get to not only
not only traffic 16 17 year olds and use
his venmo account across state lines and
sell them drugs and alcohol
and pay for sex that's what alleged
that's what joel greenberg has pled
guilty to but then he can marry him holy
[ __ ] he would love that why wouldn't
matt gats love that
but that's what they want to do folks
they want to tear down the institutions
they want to tear down the institutions
because they can build them back that's
the steve bannon donald trump fascist
trump nazi plan
do you accept you know it's here we go
again this is the most capable the most
combat credible force in the world it
has been and it will be so it has been
and will be listen to him it's not just
under biting you dumb [ __ ] this
is the same goddamn dod this is the same
military
that donald trump had for four years if
those [ __ ] missiles are so goddamn
inadequate what the [ __ ] did you do
about it and what the [ __ ] did trump do
about it huh
oh going forward not eventually down
this path to do that not if we embrace
socialism the fact that you're
embarrassed by your by your country but
no no i'm embarrassed by your leadership
i am not embarrassed for my country
this is the austin puts him on defense
here and this is the one thing that we
have to keep doing and and lloyd austin
the secretary of defense did it so well
here with matt gatz put him on his heels
this america first garbage matt gas does
not believe in america first he believes
in fascism first that's what it means
america first means let's go brandon
nazis believe in fascism first because
they want to tell you what to do they
want to tell you that they can marry
your kids they want to tell you that
they can they can sexualize your kid's
gender that's what they want to do is
tell you what the [ __ ] to do
and and secretary austin here does the
appropriate thing and puts this [ __ ]
scumbag this [ __ ] [ __ ] box
on defense that's you know that is it
inflate your failures it is [ __ ]
disgraceful that you would run down your
country you piece of [ __ ]
it is disgraceful that you're so [ __ ]
unpatriotic that you don't understand
that the [ __ ] military is the same
goddamn military that was under obama
and trump
the same dod
yeah there's different officials
different people running but it's the
same goddamn one it's the american
department of defense it's the american
military you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
with the failures of the uniformed
service members you guys said that that
russia would overrun ukraine in 36 days
you said that the taliban
this is a great [ __ ] slam dunk on
this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
listen up if the national defense
university actually worked a little more
on strategy and a little less on wokism
has it occurred to you that russia has
not overrun ukraine because of what
we've done
he walked straight into it and we could
keep doing this we can do this
everywhere folks us pro-democracy people
do not have to [ __ ] lay down and let
these fascists run all over our
arguments
you notice you notice
that matt gatz is trying to get
secretary austin
to talk about socialism and locism
in a situation where they're debating
the military
and secretary austin makes the best
point of all yeah we had a strategy to
make sure that if russia could take over
ukraine that we had a strategy for it
and we also had a strategy to maintain
that ukraine could defend itself and
they have
matt gatz you are a dumb [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
and all these republicans out here
these these republican kidnaddlers
better start to watch out because if we
keep making arguments
like secretary austin made here in the
moment
and putting them on defense
like the people in florida and disney
has with ron desantis
they are going to lose these races
they're going to lose
i don't want to leave here today without
talking about a little more about the
oklahoma
ban
a total ban on abortion might midas
touch had a tweet yesterday oklahoma
republicans just passed a near total ban
on abortion making abortion illegal from
the moment of conception
uh the bill now heads the governor's
desk for signature it's the most
reproductive or excuse me most
restrictive abortion man in the united
states
this is very important that we do not
look away from this stuff
um we we were focused on the don't say
gay bill in florida which is good
messaging and aaron parnez this morning
said that ohio now has their own
uh don't say gay bill
that utah had their version of the say
gay bill which the governor vetoed
because it only affected four children
the entire state
and he said i will not i will not let a
single bill affect only four people in
my state and he vetoed it but the
legislator overturned it
the fascist legislator in utah
overturned it
we cannot look away folks we have to
keep going at these people we cannot
stop
we have to continue
uh let's see if we can find
well there was one other thing that i
wanted to
go to today
um i really want to show that oh and i
really want to show this video let's
let's see if i can
get back to the uh
[Music]
um i think the one thing i want to show
is did you guys see the uh
the video of josh mandel his uh his new
campaign video
talking about martin luther king jr i
don't know if you've seen this or not um
let's go let's search
uh josh
josh joshie
mandel
uh speaking of ohio
um he is running for the senate seat in
ohio
this piece of [ __ ]
um he's a weirdo he is a [ __ ] weirdo
number one
he's a nazi and he uses his he uses his
uh
he uses his military on everything
like every argument he ever makes he's
like why was a marine
and because i'm a marine you can't you
can't attack me because i was a marine
here ron has the the video here play it
from ron's account not josh's account
[ __ ] that guy uh ron says in the new ad
josh mendel walks across the edmond
pettis bridge to denounce crt
and use
martin luther king jr imagery it's
really [ __ ] weird that someone would
denounce
actual critical race theory
and use mlk
imagery to do it
like historical critical race theory
to denounce it it's really weird then as
usual his answer to everything is that
he see here you go served in the marine
corps he can't be a racist since he
served in marine corps with marines who
are black he does the black friend
argument let's watch this stupid [ __ ]
ad
critical race theory is crap so the
first thing is critical race theory is
crap you see josh mandel that piece of
[ __ ] here on the edmond pettis bridge
martin luther king marks right here yeah
he did he sure did you [ __ ] you
wouldn't know anything about it and then
he goes on to say about he uses imagery
here of martin luther king and how he
was a marine but here's one of the most
important things here here it is means
of every color to come home and be
called he was with marines he has black
friends
folks josh mandel has black friends okay
and then at the end here it says pro god
pro gun pro trump so you know you know
what to do
uh in in ohio make sure that josh mandel
is the senate candidate on the
republican ticket i'm not [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
let's make this [ __ ] the
republican that we that that we go up
against
you don't want to go up against the guy
who says i got a black friend so i'm not
racist and oh by the way i'm pro-trump
you don't want to go up against that
come on give me a break
uh uh one of our good friends here of
the show
bad brad berkwith had a response you
know bad brad is a veteran of 20 years
and 28 days i believe
i think it's the exact he always he
always says i think it's 20 years and 28
days
is the uh is the exact time that bad
brad berkwit uh
here we go here it is and here's here's
here's brad's
response
to joshie
um he says my personal message to josh
mandel after using his service to
dishonoring the name of dr martin luther
king jr
um let's uh let's listen
hey josh mandel you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
talking about you were a marine
you served
but you're pro-trump
so i guess you're one of those pieces of
[ __ ] that think the [ __ ] insurrection
wasn't an insurrection
he sure as hell does that [ __ ] ad pro
trump pro guns
pro whatever
you're a pro [ __ ]
never put the name dr martin luther king
jr
and anything you have to say
and you see that shadow box right there
i probably did three times the amount of
service you did
and the problem that i have is not with
your service pal
the problem i have is you using your
service
and siding with a traitor like donald
trump
who the [ __ ] do you think you are
i'm gonna do everything in my power
after watching that video to help get
you defeated
and i'm not in your state but that's
okay
don't ever
ever defecate on the constitution
or the 20 years and 28 days i did during
war and peace again
and don't ever invoke the name dr martin
luther king out your [ __ ] mouth
because you're a piece of [ __ ]
pro-trump you're pro-asshole
thank you very much bad brad berkwood of
the bad brad berkowitz show
we we actually interviewed uh
bad brad berkwit on our show uh so go
subscribe to
and go subscribe to the youtube channel
you gotta watch that interview um brad
gets his activist
um
his knowledge of activism from his
father alvin
and it is and we show the clip
of his dad that appears on the movie
milk
um on on in that interview and it's
fantastic you guys gotta go watch it his
dad is absolutely fire now you think
brad is fire his dad whoo baby
the og the og at the fire so go watch
that thanks for joining us today
on the tony michaels podcast i really
appreciate everyone out there facebook
twitter twitch youtube you know we are
every single weekday monday through
friday right here live
youtube twitter twitch and now from the
fight
the facebook
the books of face on the midas touch
page holy moly
we're almost there we're almost to the
end of the show here
so join us tomorrow
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
and until then surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking